gigapan conversations diversity and
inclusion in the community we are in
soweto the biggest suburb of
johannesburg home to half of the 8
million inhabitants of the South African
business capital the population here is
exclusively black people who were
victims of racial segregation for 40
years one of the great symbols of this
fight is hector pieterson a 13 year old
school boy killed by police on jun 16
1976 as he took part in a demonstration
against the obligatory teaching of
Afrikaans the language of the state
imposed segregation that day the police
opened fire on the marchers and killed
23 people hector pieterson was the
youngest victim this place here this
memorial is like dedicated to those kids
who gave up their lives for us today now
we've got rights to learn in any java
languages if your closet you can linen
clothes are in English Zulu Lennon zulan
English so then the a dream was
fulfilled today we wish they were here
to see that all the hard work all that
well they all that the pain that they
fault is not a still alive today it's
possible they were preparing the future
for us cinelli an ascender are already
the students of tomorrow thanks to this
futuristic tool called the gigapan this
robot developed with the collaboration
of NASA to study Mars takes panoramic
views of the earth automatically sanela
an ascender are two of the 1200 students
in the public school of Soweto one of
four schools in the world to be chosen
by UNESCO ibe an Associated schools
network and Carnegie Mellon University
their mission to test the gigapan today
their assignment is to make a report
about their local area it doesn't take
them long to figure out how this new
machine works what happens it's like
it's taking small pictures small
pictures then it comes into it is your
pin when they stitch them and they
become one big
panorama back at the school cinelli an
ascender are eager to discover the
results of their work in this memory
card ARCA Japan's of Soweto their
personal vision of their area a program
assembles them and reconstitutes each
panoramic picture in high definition up
to 600 million pixels thanks to the
large zoom capacity details become
apparent which are invisible to the
naked eye once the images are downloaded
onto a special site which can store up
to 4,000 photos the Giga pans are sent
to three partner schools throughout the
world one of which is in Pittsburgh in
the United States these images will be
the starting point of an intercultural
exchange here in Soweto the children are
learning how to use computers thanks to
the introduction of the GigaPan a tool
which is helping to break down a digital
divide and to create a worldwide social
network to foster mutual understanding
this is a very exciting project and its
potentials for education are really
exciting because it allows students
self-discovery enables them to go
through a panorama and zoom in and two
and two areas that they really like so
this is a self-discovery a conversation
with other students and it can be
implicated in various subjects when the
children are supposed to document the
world with the GigaPan suddenly they
need to think where are the places in so
into the historical significance where
was the apartheid anti-apartheid
struggle happening and when they go
there physically
japan with a new I they're seeing a
place that's very important historically
and this causes them to do new research
on the history of their very own culture
and region so the gigapan becomes a
catalyst to help them understand their
place better and to communicate that
idea to other people better we're in
downtown Johannesburg this is called the
museum Africa of the business capital
cinelli ascender and the other students
from their school have been invited here
they have come to admire their own
photographic work printed out in large
format their dialogues with other
students from the Caribbean and the
United States are also on show illa the
researcher from Carnegie Mellon and
Christopher from UNESCO have organized
this GigaPan exhibition we can see the
Soweto Township and the homes of
apartheid but also the regina mundi
church target of police operations
during apartheid and the shopping center
a symbol of the economic development of
Soweto means my right and even the
kitchen in a sender's family home I wish
my little cousin with JCC this is my
heart that's why I do but I I took it at
home because my aunt repeat like um the
traditional food I've benefited a lot
from this project because even
newspapers retching apart because I am
the cameraman of the school I checked
the pictures for the school and
everything so I'm very it's that this
the newspapers were writing articles
about me which I could put to put on my
CV so I also pgp posting my
confidence yeah congratulations a
diploma for students who can use the
GigaPan at the moment this robot is
still in an experimental phase but it is
becoming a curricular innovation aimed
at supporting learning processes on a
global scale it may be put to service to
teach subjects such as history geography
or literature a tool of peace throughout
the world because the objective of the
GigaPan is to bring people together so
that they can learn to live together
better in 2010 johannesburg will begin
to unite people from all over the world
in this stadium the venue for the next
world cup but you just love me yeah I
think it's good because I participate a
lot even like in the classroom I'm like
always my hand up in my heart so I think
it's good in that sense I think my
teachers are my guidance to you know
they are there to help me figure out who
I am because I spend most of my time at
school like during school days and
whatnot so they basically like help me
see our things and basically as their
for guidance so that's why it's
important because if so not there then
if there are like passive teachers who
just so I sit in the staff room and you
know not be in the classroom then I
don't think I'd be the person I am big
up to the teachers if ministers could
like two programs which can improve our
conference which can increase our
self-esteem one to live life to the
fullest chili left he championed have
never spoken to a limiter minister if I
experience I mean my myself conference
with who blow if they come if they can
just if they can have like be close to
us listen to our problems hear what you
have to say because there's a lot to let
you have to offer
I found FL policy sudirman news even
besoin de lemos revell ave ste odon
affirmation allu development
professional distance in yo phone
Eleanor Cosmo escutcheon Idaho sauce I
found am pretty lazy girl Lizzie level
is a senior met hope want evil strategy
dupatta saj I don't see if it was one to
check off
you